hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast evolution of standardization
in laboratory medicine I am deep
mystical and on behalf of siemens
healthcare I will be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by lab routes comm the leading
social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by siemens
healthcare siemens healthcare is one of
the world's largest suppliers of medical
infrastructure and is a leader in
medical imaging laboratory diagnostics
and clinical IT for more information
please visit www gmail com / healthcare
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the Cree green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we will try to answer as many
questions as we can further you can
enlarge your slide screen by clicking on
the icon at the right hand corner of the
slide window the lower right corner if
you would have any technical problems
viewing or here in this presentation
please click on the support button
reaches on the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button on
the lower left so now I would like to
introduce today's speaker professor dr.
Linda Tim pond she is professor emeritus
of analytical chemistry statistics and
quality control method development and
validation she is also former director
of the laboratory for analytical
chemistry IDMS reference laboratory at
the University of Gant in Belgium a
poverty Professor Tim pond has spent
most of her career developing and
validating reference measurement
procedures using isotope dilution gas
chromatography and liquid chromatography
mass spectrometry and this for the
analysis of many components in serum and
plasma these have included clinical
chemistry analytes steroid hormones
thyroid hormones peptides and vitamin
metabolites by establishing metrological
traceability and assessing the tunas and
accuracy of hierarchically lower methods
the routine methods in laguardia
medicine she has worked with the eminent
standardization and certification
authorities in addition to sharing the
ifcc Committee on standardization of
thyroid hormones she is also worked in
research project for different ivd
manufacturers worldwide and been
involved in proficiency testing /
external quality assessment she worked
with accreditation bodies and
governmental organizations so this was
the introduction from my side i would
like to hand it over now to Linda please
Linda
thank you did Mark for these kind
introduction and I also want to welcome
all of you pull out in for attending
this life webinar and I said before I
will present on the evolution of
standardization in laboratory medicine
before I start I want to make a
declaration of interest I receive
consultancy and speakers fees from two
companies from toso and Simmons so we
can start now and I can tell you that I
constructed my presentation in such a
way that after this session you
participants will be able to identify
the rationale for standardization in
laboratory medicine and the benefits
thereof to describe the basic design of
the standardization process and its
evolution to learn the importance of
using panels of clinically relevant
samples in the standardization process
to identify the requirements to be met
before stabilization can be implemented
in practice and to understand what is
required after standardization and I
start with the first question where does
standardization stands for well it is a
process intended to accomplish
reasonable comparability and/or
interchangeability of results produced
by different measurement procedures and
in practice the process comes down to
establishing so-called metrological
traceability to internationally agreed
measurement standards the next question
why do we need standardization in
laboratory medicine well this is because
our discipline faces the problem the
different ivd test gives different
results and actually that problem was
recognized very early in the history of
korattur emedicine by people who might
call in this slide the naggers and I
refer first to Carly who observed
already in 1973 that there was a problem
and who published in clinical chemistry
an ID whose time has come that ID was
trueness and accuracy of measurement
then a decade later there was stips who
published again in the same journal
accuracy and clinical chemistry does
anybody care so apparently after the
call by Carly nothing spectacular
happened and I called myself also a
nagger since I refer here in this slide
to a publication from 2008 with the
title accuracy in clinical chemistry who
will kiss sleeping beauty awake well in
that publication I informed the clinical
community that in fact all the tools
were available to establish metrological
traceability but that it was time to
make use of them and of course all those
calls were driven by the conviction that
laboratory medicine data should be
searched at the aloe correct diagnosis
of disease therapy and patient
monitoring for which we need
standardization or establishment of
metrological traceability the benefit of
working with standardized essays is that
they are fit to address modern clinical
and public health needs such as that
laboratory data should have absolute
clinical utility with unconditional
safety for the patient they should also
allow applicability of consistent
standards of medical care which required
the use of common clinical decision
limits the possibility to develop and
use
evidence-based clinical practice
guidelines also the possibility to
aggregate data from several studies
research studies so that research can be
translated into patient care and disease
prevention activities and in an era
where the mobility of patients is huge
and where the patient has the habit to
go for a second or even third opinion
interchangeability of laboratory results
is of utmost importance so that they can
be part of electronic patient records a
next question I returned to metrological
traceability and let us look how it is
defined well in this regard I refer to
the international vocabulary of
metrology abbreviated as the theme from
the ISIL the VIP comprises the basic and
general concepts of metrology and
associated terms it's really the Bible
of our discipline well under two point
41 metrological traceability is defined
as the property of a measurement result
by the result can be related to a
reference through documented unbroken
chain of calibrations there is a note to
clarify what a reference is well it can
be a definition of a measurement unit
through its practical realization or a
measurement procedure or a measurement
standard there is also note that refers
to the fact that sometimes metrological
traceability is simply abbreviated to
traceability I do not know whether those
definitions help you a lot but let us
continue and let us look into the
anchors of metrological traceability and
you may wonder how broad the array of
anchors is I start with the first one
the metric anchor well you should know
that in former
x several metric units were in used to
communicate on measurements in various
disciplines however there was no real
coordination and this was a motivation
first for the metre convention and later
on for the coffee lounge in irondequoit
a mizzou to develop and agree on a
coherent measurement system the
so-called system and the national unity
or SI unit system well this unit system
was intended to communicate in a
standardized manner on measurements all
over the world the IFC see also adopted
that unit basis and as you know in our
discipline the mole is the SI base the
mole stands for the amount of substance
or the mole per liter the derived unit
for the amount of substance
concentration the next anchor is the
measurement anchor and here I refer
again to the film where a measurement is
defined as the process of experimentally
obtaining quantity values that can
reasonably be attributed to a quantity
and you should know that a particular
quantity require specification of three
elements being the system the component
and the kind of quantity for example the
plasma for the system glucose for the
component and the amount of substance
concentration for the kind of quantity
in the beam a particular quantity
subject to measurement is called the
measurand and now very important is to
know that in the vin the quantity is
defined the measurand better set is
defined as the quantity intended to be
measured not the quantity that we
measure but intended to be measured for
the diagnostic application the next
anchor is the metrological concept
anchor and in this regard I go back to
Cali and tips indeed in answer to the
call by cali tips proposed a
for a comprehensive measurement system
in clinical chemistry that was of course
the precursor of what we know today as
reference measurement system and it was
the intention to use that model as a
calibration hierarchy and with the aid
of the National Institute of Standards
and Technology tits began to give that
model shape in the United States but
very soon there were also several
activities in Europe in this regard
there is of course also a regulatory
anchor and in Europe it is laid down by
the directive published in 1998
demanding that manufacturers demonstrate
the metrological traceability of their
in vitro diagnostic medical devices
before they can receive siiii marking in
u.s. you have of course the FDA
regulation the 510 K clearance and
apparently that regulation moves more
and more from the predicate device to
the traceable device and it is a fact
that other countries as those listened
in listed in this slide seem to follow
that trend of course legislation
prescribes certain requirements but
never tells how those requirements
should be met and for this we have the
global ISO anchor lay down in several
ISO standards and I start with the ISO
17 5 11 which recommends that for
establishment of mythological
traceability a reference measurement
system should be used you heard that I
said recommend indeed these standards
are not compulsory for the ivd industry
but they know that by using them they
will comply with legislation with regard
to the requirements of the key elements
of the reference measurement system I
mean the reference measurement
procedures materials and
reference measurement laboratories well
there is another ISO standard serious
215 193 through 195 where they are
described and I show you here a
flowchart demonstrating how the
reference measurement system looks like
and you will immediately recognize
certain anchors that we discussed before
at the top you see the measurand and
units for expression of measurement
results at the level below you see the
unit realization in a crystalline
material certified for its purity and
then the reference measurement system
consists of a combination of materials
and measurement procedures and the
combination is in such a way that the
material always is used to calibrate a
measurement procedure and the latter is
used to assign values to the material or
calibrator at a level below excuse me so
by applying that reference measurement
system in an unbroken way one comes at
the button that a result produced for a
patient sample by a calibrated routine
si is traceable to the SI of course
within the constraints of measurement
uncertainty generated at each level of
measurement in this slide you see the
different organizations responsible for
the key elements of the hierarchically
higher part of the reference measurement
system these are the CG p.m. for the
establishment of the coherent unit
system the IFC see for the definition of
the relevant component in the measurand
the national metrology institutes for
the production and certification of
reference materials reference
laboratories or whatever competent
analytical laboratories for the
development and validation of reference
measurement procedures and
laboratories preferably work on the
network conditions to apply reference
measurement procedures either for the
establishment or assessment of
metrological traceability and to close
now the circle of the anchors I refer to
the Joint Committee for traceability and
laboratory medicine which is an
organization that has in fact the
overarching control of the key elements
of the reference measurement system
indeed they have a procedure in place to
verify that claimed reference
measurement procedures materials and
laboratories are conformed with the
aforementioned ISO standards and when
they are they are listed in the database
which is available publicly available
for potential users so now that we have
seen the theory of metrological
traceability rationale for establishing
it the concepts and the anchors and
reference measurement system can we now
safely say that that theory was capable
to warrant that metrological
traceability was established in our
discipline well personally when I
entered as young scientist the clinical
chemistry I thought that establishing
metrological traceability would be a
fast-flowing River easily overcoming
obstacles indeed I thought that by
developing one after the off other
reference measurement procedure industry
would welcome that finally they got the
key to establishing traceability and
doing so would become the evidence
itself you see here all the reference
measurement procedures I developed
throughout my career however getting
older I had to observe that obstacles
may cause the river to meander and slow
down indeed I realized that
the age-old tension between theory and
practice and for myself and other
colleagues working in the fields it took
some time before we realized that as
nice a theory can be it must find its
way into practice because it has value
and you can believe me finding that way
into practice was very difficult and I
can illustrate this maybe by the most
striking example that of insulin
measurement as you know as early as 1959
yellow one person developed the first in
saline amino SC for measurement in
plasma that was really the basis for
laboratory magazine in endocrinology it
even led to the nobel prize in
physiology and medicine in 1977 for
Rosaline yellow well can you understand
that more than half a decade after that
invention insulin as they still are not
standardized well this was because there
were several obstacles causing problems
to establishing metrological
traceability however luckily there was
an evolution towards solving those
problem and that's what I'm going to
deal with you now in my the rest of my
presentation well the obstacles that
were encountered in the beginning were
coming from insufficient attention to
the definition of the component or
analyte in the measurement and related
aspects and I will illustrate this for
SI and non SI analytes there was also
insufficient attention to the validity
of reference materials and reference
measurement procedures to the potential
noncommittal bility of reference
materials and the importance of panels
of native samples so insipid attention
was
aight to the entrance equality of the
esses examined for standardization and
the extent of standardization to achieve
but as i said before there was an
evolution toward solving the problems
and i start with the first obstacle
insufficient definition of the component
or analyte in the measurement and i
would like to recall that the
measurement is the basis of the
reference measurement system that it is
defined as the quantity intended to be
measured for the diagnostic application
it requires specification of three and
three elements a component or the
analytes the kind of quantity and the
system and the definition of the
measurement is determining for the
reference measurement procedure and its
specificity well it is very important
that before attempting to develop a
reference measurement system that there
is a unique vocal definition of the
measurement and that there is a general
agreement definition that cannot be
sufficiently emphasized and it's also
important that certain conceptual
aspects related to the definition are
respected well I will exemplify this by
way of SI analytes as I analytes or
those that are physical chemically well
defined for example when we speak of
thyroxine and serum and plasma everyone
knows that thyroxine is chemically
well-defined we exactly now the chemical
structure well the definition of the
component in the measurement for
thyroxine is absolutely unproblematic I
go now to the next example that of total
25-hydroxyvitamin d
which might be a little bit more
complicated and the reason for this is
that in fact the term total refers to
the fact that we speak of mixture
analysis indeed total 25-hydroxyvitamin
D is defined as 25 hydroxy d2 and d3
with exclusion of the three FP forms of
the two metabolites again the tool
metabolites or chemically well defined
however the difficulty is in the fact
that we had to add up the measurements
for the two molecules and when I said
before that certain conceptual aspects
related to the definition need to be
respected I can exemplify this for total
25 hydroxy d analyst analysis indeed the
definition of the measurement requires
that routine amino acids are capable to
equimolar measurements of the mixture
components 25 hydroxy d2 and d3 so the
accent is on a queen molar measurement
since we have to add up the measurement
results for the day 2 and d3 metabolite
we have to express measurement results
in nano mole per liter which is not
interchangeable with nanogram per ml
logically notes because the two
molecules have a different molecular
weight and since the tree epi forms are
excluded from the definition of the
measurand there is the requirement that
the routine asses have sufficient
specificity to not measure the tree I
perform that means immunoassays should
not cross-react with the tree I perform
and routine ms methods must have
sufficient chromatographic resolution to
resolve the EPI form another obstacle as
I said was that insufficient attention
was paid to the validity of reference
measurement proceed
cheers and reference materials indeed
reference materials must comprise the
Defiant components in the measurand and
the reference measurement procedure must
be specific and capable of accurate
measurement of the component in the
measurement well beforehand there was no
mechanism in place to verifies that a
reference material and reference
measurement procedure really was a valid
one I can exemplify this for example for
organic analytes it was taught in the
beginning that whatever IDMS method
would serve the purpose of a reference
measurement procedure because of the
potential of a mess too accurate and
specific measurement however this was a
misunderstanding because an ID ms method
must have a certain quality must have a
certain specificity and quality of
performance before it can be claimed to
be a reference measurement procedure the
designer of the method has to develop
that method towards that quality but
finally has to prove that the quality is
there by a thorough validation well
luckily the evolution is in the fact
that we have now the JCT LMK database to
warrant the validity of the listed
reference materials and measurement
procedures I now go to the definition of
the component in the measurement for non
SI analytes you see here a very nice
iceberg and you see that yes I analytes
only are the tip of the iceberg all the
other analytes that we determine in our
discipline are so called non si analytes
those are analyzed that either or not
defined yet or not well defined thus for
which we cannot apply as I units instead
we have to apply arbitrary units the
known as I units as for example defined
by
wh 0 and most of those analytes are
heterogeneous analytes I refer for
example to tumor and bone and cardiac
markers to all the proteins that have
been elucidated through proteome
projects and new markers like cytokinins
and growth hormones and I will
illustrate a problem of defining the
component or analyte in the measurement
for thyroid stimulating hormone that is
a glycoprotein that is heterogeneous
this when we measure TSH and serum or
plasma we know that we do not measure
one molecule for the family of molecules
thus we speak about mixture analysis
indeed TSH comprises two non covalently
linked subunits and alpha and a beta
subunit the Alpha subunit is common to
all the glycoproteins the beta is
specific for TSH and both soup units
comprised a certain amount of amino
acids in a certain sequence and also
carbohydrate change well the
heterogeneity for TSH is in the amino
acid sequence and the isoforms but also
in the glycosylation pattern as shown in
literature that glycosylation pattern is
disease-specific so no wonder that it is
difficult to define the component in the
measurement when we look in the in
practice with regard to mixture analysis
for TSH well we observe that all amino
acids claim that they measure the amount
of substance concentration of human TSH
and serum and plasma as I said before we
know that we measure a family of
components and until recently that
family of components was not yet
formally defined and we express
measurement results in arbitrary units
the melee international
needs per liter as defined by the wh 0
international reference preparation the
TSH 80 / 55 8 or 81 / 5652 exactly the
same materials but we should also
realize that in fact TSH is a component
in transition from s non si tu SI unit
indeed one day it will maybe be possible
to measure a disease-specific TSH and to
develop a reference measurement
procedure for it this then we will also
be able to express measurement results
in SI units of course as long as we have
to do with a nun as I analyze it is the
question should we already attempt to
standardize or not yet well in this
regard I would like to recall that
before we answer that question we have
to be sure what do we intend to measure
and in this regard I would like to refer
to Roger Eakins who is a very estimated
scientist because of his pioneering work
in the 60s with regard to the
development of methods for ligand
measurement for hormones and free
hormones and when he was asked that
question what do we intend to measure in
case of mixture analysis his reply was
at least surprising since he said
insofar as the antigenic substances
present and standards or test samples
are molecularly heterogenous an amino si
is invalid hence any attempt to
standardize analytically and valid
immunoassays will inevitably fail that
was Eakins the purest however Eakins was
a very intellectual man he could also be
a pragmatist since in the same
publication he continued it is
nevertheless possible to visualize
circumstances in which an S
system Bow analytically invalid in the
strictest sense responds only to a
particular atomic group coming to the
molecules are of substances differing in
overall structures and you even refer to
TSH in other words that's saying that
there might be a pragmatic solution for
immunoassays that recognize epitopes and
in very eight peptide sequences well in
this regard I would like now to refer to
a proposal by an ifcc committee for
standardization of thyroid function
tests of which I am the chair holder
indeed we proposed that TSH asses could
be harmonized instead of standardized
what's the difference between
harmonization and standardization well
in fact both processes aim at the same
objective to make essays comparable
however harmonization is a pragmatic
approach standardization is a pure
metrological approach so we see
harmonization as an intermediary
solution until as I units are possible
until a reference measurement procedure
is available and the committee defined
the component as human TSH intact form
the total form with glycosylation
encountered in a diagnostic application
which should be specified for example
TSH for the diagnosis of uncomplicated
hypo versus hyperthyroidism or euthyroid
ism we also propose to make use of a
surrogate reference measurement
procedure we refer to the use of a
statistical all procedure trip mean from
a method comparison with a clinically
relevant panel and participation of as
many asses as possible I assure you hear
the proof of concept of harmonization
and I do it by way of TSH so we
performed a method comparison with
16 immunoassays and you see at the left
hand a presentation of the percentage
difference of the results by all the
immunoassays for a panel of samples you
see that I give the most discrepant
essays different colors the blue symbols
and the red triangles and you see that
before the harmonization process the
differences there are differences
between the amino acids but after the
harmonization process you see that the
interassay differences are eliminated
that the percentage sa residuals are
nicely centered around zero and that the
remaining dispersion is from winning as
the effects I move now to another
obstacle and that obstacle was that in
the first beginning they always tried to
accomplish standardization by use of a
reference material dissolved in an
artificial matrix well in this regard
you should know that a reference
material always is to a certain extent
process for example the TSH reference
material that i mentioned before is
purified cadaver between turing well
because of this reference material is
not suited for standardization however
the problem is that it was not realized
that this was effect and I show you gain
for TSH that in fact of the in spite of
the fact that all essays are traceable
to the same reference material the wh 0
when they measure the same panel of
samples and we plot the mean for each of
the essays you see that they are apart
from each other and the most discrepant
essays give a mean that is at 163 and at
2.26 so quite a difference more than
thirty percent so in spite of the
like that they are all calibrated with
the same reference material they do not
give comparable results you may wonder
how that comes well this is because
reference materials also are so called
non commutable that's a gain
meteorological term but in layperson
terms that means that a reference
material does not behave with a routine
as they as native samples do and of
course the behavior of native samples
are the reference because any routine
essay is developed for optimal
measurement of native example and you
see here in this graph presentation of
the mathematical relationship between
the results by a reference measurement
procedure in the abscess and a routine
essay in the ordinate and you see that
mathematical relationship for clinical
samples that's what you see in the black
symbols and for three reference
materials these are the red symbols and
you immediately see that the reference
materials have another mathematical
relationship between the two measurement
procedures than the native samples so
apparently the dose-response with the
routine essays is different for the
reference materials than for the
component in its natural environment
serum or plasma luckily there was an
evolution in debt it was found how to
overcome that issue of non comet ability
and the solution is in the use of panels
of native samples in the reference
measurement system at the level of the
working calibrator so that is absolutely
permissible in the iso 17 5 11 and I in
this regard I would like to bring
tribute to a Swedish colleague in
Markham who was the first one to speak
about the issue of non committal bility
of reference materials if used for
calibration
no essays and he exemplified that by way
of cortisol immunoassay and his solution
was to use native samples assigned with
values by reference measurement
procedure instead of reference materials
well I can tell you when I entered the
field hover decade later I took your
camp as my big example and in this way I
came became maybe one of the biggest
protagonist of the use of native samples
in the standardization process I show
you here again the proof of concept for
use of serum panels I show you another
example of the CSD ft 3 d 4 here the
metal comparison was done against a
reference measurement procedure and you
see that before the standardization all
the immunoassays had strongly a strong
negative bias in comparison to the
reference method and they also were
apart from each other well after
standardization on the basis of that
panel of native samples you see that the
bias to the reference measurement
procedure is completely removed and that
again the residual dispersion is nearly
entirely new to within se effects
another obstacle I mentioned before was
insufficient attention to the entrance
equality of the essays examined for
Standardization well luckily there is
now the evolution that recent projects
perform a method comparison and apply a
measurement protocol so that they can
infer the general performance attributes
of the essays examined for
Standardization that's very important to
also know the attributes on native
samples in addition the evolution is
such that it is more and more realized
that standardization only emphasizes the
average result and now
looks into the quality of performance on
the at the level of the individual
sample well therefore recent projects
now used to look into the total error
performance and evaluated total error
against specifications for example those
based on the biological variation model
for example again my CS TFT group looks
into the total error I show you here the
example for free t4 be use as total
error specification those based on
biological variation being nine point
six percent and after the method
comparison we recalibrate the data to
the reference measurement procedure and
we plot the differences and we include
in the plots also the specifications for
total error and in this plot we then can
visually show the intrinsic quality of
the essays in terms of the total error
by looking into the number of
differences outside the specifications
for example at the left hand I show you
an SC that has very good entrance
equality only one difference is outside
the total error specification at the
right hand in contrast you see an essay
with a poor entrance equality several
differences are outside the total error
specification this means when that se a
standardized in average the result will
be ok but at the level of the individual
sample the uncertainty will be huge
another obstacle in the beginning was
insufficient attention to the extent of
traceability luckily there is now the
evolution that recent projects first set
to specifications to achieve by the
standardization projects and in this
regard my group did I think very nice
work by defining the specifications for
the 25 hydroxy reference measurement
system though specification
shins and that model was adopted by the
CDC and vitamin D sanitation program and
the approach was such that we started by
setting specifications for the routine
methods in terms of imprecision and bias
and we then cascaded down those
specifications to come to the
specifications for the reference
measurement procedure and we said the
imprecision should be such that it is
only half the imprecision permissible
for the routine method and the bias
should be only one-third the bias
allowable for the routine methods and
the same cascading down for the
uncertainty of the primary calibrator
which should only consume one third of
the budget for the bias of the reference
measurement procedure so now the
question after establishment of
meteorological traceability can be can
it be implemented from one day to
another well certainly the answer is no
that is not possible the implementation
needs to be carefully prepared in
particular where when the impact of
standardization is huge and for example
for frida for that impact will be huge
you see here that the numerical values
of provided by the amino acids of the
standardization will increase by fifty
to eighty percent that also means that
reference intervals will change well
that impact will in fact be a high risk
for use of standardized essays and
therefore it is necessary to first
undertake certain actions to wave away
that risk for example by liaising with
regulatory authorities with key
stakeholders such as laboratories
clinicians and also patients by way of
publications and meetings by doing
risk-benefit analysis at all levels of
stakeholders and educate steak houses
about the impact and changes and when
all this has been carefully
earth then still it is very important to
coordinate the implementation of the
standardized and harmonized essays by
all manufacturers at the same point in
time and worldwide what about the period
after mythological traceability well
then it is still important to control
the implementation of standardization
under field conditions by performing
dedicated external quality assessment or
PT service for laboratories and in this
regard my group developed a project and
power ivd globe to do so for example we
perform dedicated eqa with native Syrah
of course we sent the panel of native
Syrah to representative laboratories for
several manufacturers and we let them
measure the samples and we make them
different plots we work with
specifications state-of-the-art
specifications but also biological
specifications for the bias and in this
way we can visually show to the clinical
community how well the landscape of
establishment of traceability is at some
times we can point to certain
manufacture who has problems as the one
here in these graphs with represented by
the black triangles it's also important
to assess the sustainability of the
standardization status on the field
conditions by working with another part
of our projects laboratory sent us the
daily medians for that outpatients we
then plot the moving median in time the
user has a user interface where they can
see whether their performance is stable
as here in the left hand the gray zone
is stability zone or whether they have a
drifting performance or a bias in
performance also important is that
manufactures try to participate in
international projects as there are for
example the cdc vitamin d
colonization certification program which
helps manufacturers to establish
traceability which also looks into the
success of traceability and
sustainability of traceability and when
manufacturers succeed well then they are
on the website of the of the CDC and
this of course is valuable information
for you abor Ataris so now i en't with
asking or their success stories for
Standardization well of course there are
several ones such as the National
glucose feminization program the
national cholesterol education program
the national kidney disease program you
already mentioned vitamin D salinization
program and of course multiple ifcc
projects so I give no words to did mark
who will look into the questions that
you post throughout my presentation and
I will be pleased to answer them Thank
You Linda for that very informative
presentation before we get started on a
question and answer session I would like
you to remind the audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the window
lower left of the window we will try to
answer as many questions as possible and
I will look which questions have come in
but at the moment I don't see any
question for display so maybe I should
wait so I will wait a certain time
whether question will appear or not
sarita in car
the audience to to ask questions so
please don't fear that your question is
may be superfluous or that it is not
relevant so I i encourage you still have
no question so the first law it's more
congratulations to us there were several
times audio breaks so I would like to
know if your presentation is recorded
and for future review Linda I gives it a
question to you is it recorded for and
for future radio I think so it will be
available this webinar I think through
Simmons yes indeed it is recorded it
will be available later second question
oh now they come in so uh second
question is can you expand upon a
difference between harmonization and
standardization Linda yes well
harmonization is as I said a more
pragmatic approach whereas
standardization is a real metrological
approach that works according to the
concept of reference measurement system
it makes use of reference measurement
procedures of patient samples are signed
with values by the reference measurement
procedure so that is for as I analytes
and as I traceability is established
which means that then trueness is
established in contrast harmonization is
a pragmatic approach it is in fact
allowed alignment of essays to a certain
basis but one cannot see that's the
trueness but it is an intermediary
solution that
makes that results are comparable so if
one day we can harmonize the SH essays
all essays will give comparable results
so another one very interesting one well
every honor light be standardized
eventually well I think there is still a
long way to go of course it would be the
intention to standardize every analyte
but this requires of course that
reference measurement procedures are
developed and they are very expensive so
it can either take some time or it it
will depends on how willing
manufacturers or and probably also how
willing laboratories are to pay for the
sanitization process but of course that
would be the ideal that all analytes can
be standardized on the other hand I
think that also the harmonization we can
reach a lot and it's not that expensive
have a question refer to drug level
measurements for example lithium levels
so which samples should be considered
for Standardization I think here is the
same also for standardization of the
essays for measurement of lithium one
should make use of native samples
assigned to gain a target by a reference
measurement procedure the question
according to the slides Candace lights
be made available to the participants
please and so on i think we had already
that questions so uh this slide i think
will be available later then there's
also thank to linda for a nice
presentation so I think there is no real
answer that you have to give lenders
like I go to the next question could you
please give an actual example if
possible of
how harmonization and standardization
will work in practice well in fact both
will work with the method on the basis
of metal comparison we're all
immunoassays measure clinically relevant
panel we then apply a recalibration to
the target for that panel either set by
a surrogate reference measurement
procedure in case of harmonization or
set by the reference measurement
procedure in case of standardization so
all manufacturers will recalibrate that
means reassign the values of their
master calibrators and afterwards all
the essays will give comparable results
so that's the process of harmonization
and standardization okay there is
another very specific question referring
to our 25-hydroxyvitamin d
standardization linda could you please
explain what the difference is between
the cdc certification and the DSP
standardization for vitamin d well there
is no difference between the approaches
used in both projects they both make use
of isaac inform reference measurement
procedures and actually the reference
measurement procedure performed by my
laboratory was one of the reference
measurement procedures used on the VDS p
together with the witnessed and maybe
the difference between the cdc
certification program and the VDS p is
that the CDC also repeats the approach
the process year after year because
manufacturers have to prove year of the
year that they still are traceable to
the SI as the
find by the reference measurement
procedure but in fact both approaches
are the same okay now we have specific
questions referring to the quality of
reference measurement procedures and
particularly to the uncertainty there of
the CV the maximum CV and the maximum
bias for a reference measurement
procedure should that be compared to the
biological variable variability and if
you could give some maximum values for
those maybe some examples for really
quality specifications for reference
measurement procedures how are they
developed and we have some examples well
there was one slide in my presentation
where I shalt the model for
specifications of the complete reference
measurement system so for 25 hydroxy d
the imprecision for the routine methods
is derived on the basis of the
biological variation model that's ten
percent and the buyers for the routine
SI is five percent we then say the
imprecision of the reference measurement
procedure should we should be twice as
good as the imprecision of the routine
SI there's only five percent and the
bias should consume only one-third of
the bias allowable for the routine SI
does one-point-seven percent then the
uncertainty of the primary calibrator
used to calibrate reference measurement
procedure should be only one third in
terms of uncertainty one-third of the
bias allowable for the reference
measurement procedure so that's the
principle of specifications for
reference measurement procedure
commensurate with the intended use and
the intended use in the sanitization
process is of course establishing
traceability for routine asses okay yeah
there are other questions coming in but
I think we have to wrap up so I think we
have time for one last question
which is a very important one Linda
could harmonization mask deficiencies in
some analytical methods well there might
be the possibility that harmonization
mask deficiencies in some analytical
procedures on the other hand for a
project for harmonization it's also
important to look before hand in as i
said the intrinsic quality of the essays
that are harmonized so i think that
currently most projects really look into
that quality into the limitations of the
essays so i want to thank the audience
for attending that life webinar and also
for the lively discussion afterwards
there are some remarks to be made by
dick my regarding the availability of
the slides so thank you linda today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
view for six months from live date you
will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay and we invite you
to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who have maybe missed that
live event so thank you all for
participating see you next by next time
and good bye thank you bye bye